[Music]
one of the biggest challenges with
building a single page application is
making the app visible to search engines
and Link BOTS
fortunately with angular Universal we
have a reliable package for rendering
our apps on the server not only does
this provide SEO but it can also improve
the initial page load speed in today's
video you'll learn how to server-side
render an angular app then deploy it to
Google App Engine or firebase cloud
functions if you're new here like and
subscribe and make sure to follow along
with the full source code on fire ship
io let's start by talking about what
server-side rendering is and when you
would want to use it in any normal
JavaScript app whether it be angular
view or react you will provide the
browser with a JavaScript bundle then
the browser will parse that bundle of
JavaScript and figure out how to render
the HTML that's a great way to build a
modern web app because it will make the
user experience feel very fast and
responsive like a native app but the
problem is that a lot of bots out there
don't execute JavaScript so that means
if somebody shares a deep link in your
app and that link renders some kind of
dynamic content the only thing the bot
will see is your initial index.html file
so the purpose of angular Universal and
server-side rendering is to offload some
of this work to the server so when the
user first visits a deep link they'll
get some rendered HTML with the dynamic
content already included for example the
Twitter bot just wants to read the meta
tags and ahead of the document so it's
just going to grab that HTML and then
not worry about executing any JavaScript
on the page when you have just a regular
user they'll get that same pre-rendered
HTML so this usually results in a faster
initial page load then angular's
JavaScript will take over so it'll
behave just like a regular angular app
on subsequent navigations in order to
make this possible we can't really use
firebase hosting directly because it's
just a static host we need an actual
node.js server to dynamically render the
content when a page is requested we have
two good deployment options for a
firebase project Google App Engine and
firebase cloud functions there are some
trade-offs between the two but I'll show
you how to set up both of them in this
video and they can both be used on the
free tier I'm starting out from a brand
new angular 7 app and the great thing
about Universal is that there's a
schematic so we can simply add all the
boilerplate to our project by running
this command ng ad universal express
engine and then specify the client
project as your project
that will create five new files in this
project so let's take a look at each one
of those now the first one is the web
pack server config and its job is to
package and compile the server dot es
file so let's jump into server TS and
you'll see that this is our actual
Express j/s app Express is a tool that
can receive a web request and then send
a response back to the browser so
Express will save the initial request
angular Universal will kick in and
render the actual HTML and Express we'll
send that HTML as a response to the
browser you'll also see a main server
dot ES file which is just the entry
point into the server-side app and it
also has its own TS config from there
we'll jump into the app directory and
you'll see we also have an app server
module it's basically just a wrapper
around the app module and at this point
you don't have to make any changes to
any of these files once we get to the
firebase stuff I'll show you exactly
what needs to change and where so let's
go ahead and install angular fire and
firebase and then we'll jump into the
app module you'll notice one change here
and that's that the browser module is
now calling with server transition that
just allows the app to be rendered on
the server and then transition into a
normal angular app after the initial
page load from there you can import all
of the angular fire stuff that you want
to use in your project none of this
stuff is actually required for angular
universal but I'm just making the
assumption that you have firebase in
your project because there's a few
caveats that we'll look at later that
takes care of the initial setup now
let's go into the package.json and
you'll see that the ng add command added
a few new npm scripts to this file the
ones that you want to use primarily are
build SSR and serve SSR first we'll
build the app and then we'll go ahead
and serve it just to make sure
everything is working at this point now
just a quick side note I highly
recommend using node version 8.1 for
when working in your local development
environment that's the version used on
GCP and cloud functions and that's what
I use to build this tutorial after
running the build command you should see
a disk directory and inside of that you
should see a browser build and a server
build as well as a server JS file at
this point our app doesn't really do
anything so I'm going to go ahead and
generate a new component that represents
the about page for this app then we'll
have this page dynamically render its
own meta tags so can be used with a
Twitter card or any other social media
site if you run ng generate components
you'll probably get an error saying it's
missing the module you can fix that by
adding flag
with app to your command that happens
because there's two modules in the app
directory and it doesn't know which one
to use when it comes to SEO you'll most
likely want to set a title and some meta
tags when this component is rendered and
angular provides a couple of services
for you to do that called title and meta
then I'm going to create an object with
just some static data but you could also
pull this data from the database from
there we'll go ahead and inject our
dependencies in the constructor and then
with title we can just simply call set
title and then pass the dynamic data to
it then the meta service has an add tags
method which we can pass an array of
multiple meta tags you can learn how to
format meta tags by going to the Open
Graph Docs or to Twitter or Facebook
but basically angular is just going to
add these tags to the head of the
document when this component is
initialized the one thing that is very
important is that you use this service
to set the meta tags and not do it
manually on the document or window
itself for example if we wanted to get
the URL it's tempting to call window
location path name but the window
doesn't exist in node J s so this will
result in an error when we try to
server-side render the app so when using
Universal you always want to keep that
in mind and just try to avoid touching
the Dom directly so in order for this to
be useful to us we need to have this
component loaded by the router if we
jump over to the app routing module we
can just set up a single path to about
that loads the about component at this
point you should be able to load the app
in the browser just using ng serve and
you should see the meta tags in the head
of the document so at this point we have
dynamic meta tags but if we were to
share this link on social media we'd end
up with something like this and again
that's because the meta tags are
rendered by the JavaScript now let's go
ahead and serve this app with Universal
so the meta tags are rendered in advance
first run the build SSR command after
that's done run serve SSR that will
serve the app on localhost 4000 but if
you're using firebase in your project
you should end up with an error like
this that's because firebase uses a few
things in the Dom that are not available
on node by default but we can easily fix
that by just adding in polyfills for
them first install WebSockets and xhr to
into your development environment from
there go into the server TS file and
then add these two lines to the very top
of it if you're in the serve command
again it should work but it'll still
give you a couple of warnings you can
clear out these warnings by installing
these packages and that command is
available in the full
and anytime you make changes to this
file make sure to run the build SSR
command first and then serve SSR after
at this point you can go to localhost
4000 and your app should look and behave
just like a normal angular app but you
can validate that your server-side
rendering is working by opening up the
page source this is how the page looks
when it's served to the browser so
before any JavaScript is run and you
know it's working if you see your meta
tags and your dynamic title in this HTML
now we have a big decision to make do we
deploy this to Google App Engine or to
firebase cloud functions on App Engine
our project will become a containerized
app so it can be deployed on App Engine
or any other cloud and there's a free
tier for nodejs
and it will scale up automatically as
needed and the pricing works out to be
around twenty-five dollars per month per
container but they will Auto scale based
on the traffic and demand so that
pricing will vary App Engine is also
very easy to deploy to so in my opinion
it's the better way to go in most cases
but it's also possible to deploy to
cloud functions which gives you a
tighter integration with firebase and
it's hard to do a direct price
comparison but I suspect cloud functions
would be less expensive pricing is based
on the number of invocations of the
function which is free up to
125-thousand per month so those are the
trade-offs let's go ahead and deploy to
App Engine first you need to have the
Google Cloud command-line tools
installed so you should be able to run
the g-cloud command and then we'll
create a file called App Gamal the only
line you need in this file is the
runtime as nodejs 8 but you can also
specify a different scaling options here
as well when you deploy it's going to be
looking for the NPM run start command so
you'll want to go into your package JSON
and have that point to the service SR
command from there it's just a matter of
running g-cloud app deploy and that will
push the container to Google Cloud and
start running it as a service that
should take a couple minutes but when
it's done it will give you a URL and
when you go there it should have the
same exact app that we were looking at
on localhost and the nice thing about
App Engine is that we have this
dashboard where we can look at the
different versions we can look at the
debug logs and we can even look at the
source code so that was super easy now
let's take a look at cloud functions
which requires a few more steps the
first thing we want to do is run
firebase submit for hosting and
functions I'm going to use typescript
functions but the process is almost
identical for JavaScript functions from
there go ahead and point to the dist
browser directory and
you'll say yes to configuring the app as
a single page app we'll go ahead and
configure it to rewrite all of the
traffic to a cloud function instead of
the index.html like it normally does you
can name this whatever you want but I'll
just go ahead and call it SSR now we
need to see the into the functions
directory and we need a way to get our
angular code into our functions
environment because Universal needs that
source code in the runtime to render the
actual content I'm going to write a
little note script here to handle that
and to make life a little bit easier I'm
installing file system extra then we'll
create a file called CP - angularjs now
there are many different ways we can do
this but this is the way I chose to do
it
basically we just have a function that
will copy the files from the dist
directory and angular over to a dist
folder in the functions directory then
we'll also always want to remove the
copied files on each new build of cloud
functions just to make sure we're always
working with the latest angular code
from there go into the package.json for
functions and read node CP angular in
your build command and while we're in
here let's also set the engine to note 8
so that it deploys our function as a
note 8 function now we'll go to the
source index TS and write the function
itself it's actually super easy all we
have to do is take the universal app and
then pass it into an HTTP function as
you can see here we're actually
importing the universal app from our
current working directory so that's why
we have to copy it over to the functions
environment and that's all there is to
the function side of things but in order
for this to work we need to make a
couple of tweaks to the original server
code and angular open up the server TS
file and then add an export in front of
the app variable then go all the way
down at the bottom and comment out the
listener cloud functions is already
doing it listening so we don't want this
line in our code and we need to make
sure that our code gets exported as a
library that we can consume so add
library app and library target UMD and
if you have issues bundling you may want
to add firebase as an external now it's
time for the moment of truth first make
sure to rebuild your app using the build
SS our command and angular then go into
the functions directory and run the
build command there from there run
firebase serve which will serve your
hosting and your function simultaneously
hopefully everything went well and
you're seeing the rendered meta tags
when you go to localhost 5,000
if that's the case go ahead and run
firebase deploy and that will deploy the
function and hosting and now you have a
fully server-side rendered app
running on firebase cloud functions
after deploys head over to the Twitter
card validator just to make sure that
everything is working as expected I'm
gonna go ahead and wrap things up there
if you run into any issues let me know
in the comments or on slat thanks for
watching and I will talk to you soon
[Music]